It's the first of the month.
You know what that means:
Rent's due.
What's up, guys?
I'm Tyrann Mathieu, also
known as The Landlord.
They call me The Landlord
cuz I own the field and I take care of
Chiefs Kingdom. But right now my social
responsibility goes much beyond that.
A lot of people have been
impacted by COVID-19, especially
in my hometown of New Orleans.
I'm hoping to find a few families
that I can really impact and
help and love and support.
I'm looking forward to checking them out.
- I know you love New Orleans, and
I wanted to share with you a
family that could use your help.
Courtney is an extremely talented
artist and a mother of twins with
autism. Her children are Lyric and Julius.
Courtney is now a survivor of COVID-19.
Courtney was diagnosed a few weeks back,
and I honestly remember her telling me
the hardest part of fighting the virus
was not being able to touch her children.
She just hugged her son Julius
for the first time about a
week ago. And he was excited
and so was she. Thank you again, Tyrann.
This would mean the world
to Lyric and their family.
- Hey, how you doing?
- It’s good to see you.
- Good to see you too. My son is over here.
- Is that Lyric?
- Yup, that's Lyric.
- How's everybody doing? It's so
good to see you guys smiling.
- We live in New Orleans.
- Yeah.
He's from New Orleans.
- Yeah, I'm from New Orleans.
So, I mean, how has everything been?
Um, cuz I, I mean, I've heard that
you tested positive for coronavirus now.
How did that go for you?
Were you able to work?
- Well, I actually haven't been able to work
since before I was tested positive
because of them being home from school.
- Gotcha.
- And then, um, my cousin got
sick, and she also lives with us.
Unfortunately, she was hospitalized, but
I wasn't. I probably may have needed to
be, but I couldn't leave my kids at home.
So we both fully recovered.
Um, we still have the aftereffects.
Sometimes I feel like I need, like,
a breathing treatment from an asthma
pump, but that was in, like, March.
I didn't get to hug them
until late April, early
May.
So, can you imagine living in the same
house with your kids and not having
any kind of physical contact?
- I want to ask Lyric a question if she's listening.
- Sure.
- Hi.
- How was it, how was it for you
when, when your mom was sick
and she wasn't able to hug you?
How did that go for you?
- Since I wasn't able to hug my mom,
I hugged my brother a lot.
- That's so good.
I want to get personal
with you for a second.
I want to ask you, cuz I, I
mean, I've heard, I've heard it.
You've told me. You
haven't been able to work.
Um, you know, you've
been self-quarantined.
How has it been financially for you?
- I was without a car for 10 years,
and on March 13, the day
before everything started
shutting down and everything, I bought a car.
So now I have a car note.
I have this
car insurance that's
higher than my car note.
I'm behind on the water bill,
behind on the light bill.
Um, and just trying to keep food in
the house. Man, these two teenagers
can eat you out of house and home.
- [Lyric laughing]
- Well, you, you know my nickname is
The Landlord, and I'm, and I'm
the person that runs the field.
So I control everything.
And then also I take care of the kingdom.
So I'm always thinking
about my community and,
and people in need. Um, and I've heard your story.
You just shared it with me.
And I'm so grateful that
I was able to talk to you.
And I feel like you deserve so much
more—um, really everything you've,
you've been able to overcome.
Um, I want to be able to help you.
I want to show you some love.
So right now I want you
to check your texts
for me, please, if you could.
- Oh wow! Thank you!
- You're welcome.
- Thank you so, so much.
- So, I sent you one month's rent, and
then my friends at Zelle, they were
able to donate the next month's rent.
So you're actually going to be
covered for the next two months.
You know, I love my community.
And so any time I'm able to hear
stories like this, I always want to
be a part of those people's lives.
Cuz it always helps change mine.
Um, so it was good talking to you today.
It was good seeing you guys.
And I wish you guys
the best going forward.
I wish you guys much, much health.
- And to you.
- And thank you. Thank you so much for looking out.
You know, not everybody's out there
looking out for the little people, you know.
Thank you so much for looking out for me.
- Thank you.
- And, and these two little ones I
got right here. They're 15, but they're still little ones.
- Yes, yes. They'll always be your babies.
- Yes. Always. Always.
- Bye.
- Bye-bye. Take care.